[Music]
movies can be the perfect way for
couples to pass the time they're
entertaining easily shared experiences
and they tend to teach us a thing or two
about each other's tastes there are some
movies however that are probably best
viewed alone so as to avoid arguments
general awkwardness or sudden distrust
these films are totally worth your time
as long as you're by yourself fair
warning there are spoilers aplenty about
each of these titles gone girl Dave
adventures adaptation of the creepy
mystery novel gone girl is the kind of
movie that can easily leave partners
second-guessing what they really know
about one another
chances are your lover isn't going to
disappear and frame you for it just out
of spite but given the graphic lengths
to which Rosamund Pike's amazing amy was
willing to go to deliver payback tube in
a flicks cheating Nick Dunne it's just
better to avoid the potential for
romantic fallout that might result from
sharing of viewing that said it's still
totally worth a solo screening because
it's still a pretty solid adaptation of
an intensely gripping narrative sweet
November for a movie that's been billed
as a romantic drama sweet November sure
has its twistier moments the film
centers around Charlize Theron character
Sara Deever who at first seems like your
prototypical precocious Manic Pixie
dream girl but as Keanu Reeves Nelson
Moss soon discovers she has a
devastating secret beneath all those
scarves for some this might seem like a
heart-wrenching story of star-crossed
love but for others it might just be
maddening that this poor schmuck could
be duped into giving his heart to
someone so tragic in the interest of
avoiding unnecessary arguments on the
home front
this one's best reserved for a solo
screening unfaithful any attempt at
discussing this movie is going to start
an argument
guaranteed Diane Lane's character Connie
summer is a married mother in a lustrous
marriage but that all changes when she
comes across Olivier Martinez his
character Paul Martel the resulting
affair is sensuous and intoxicating but
has grave consequences for her marriage
and her paramour
without spoiling all the details let's
just say that crimes of the heart aren't
the only ones that result from her
duplicity it's what happens
that's bound to be a point of severe
derision from those who regard adultery
to be the ultimate deal-breaker so to
avoid the conversation catastrophe
that's sure to ensue from watching this
movie on date night save it for a rainy
day all by your lonesome the good girl
Jennifer Aniston fans will definitely
want to see this movie because the good
girl marks an impressive departure from
the generic rom-com fare she's usually
found in that said this one is also
completely not safe for couples the
movie revolves around her store clerk
character Justine being stuck in an
emotionless marriage until she's swept
up by her handsome I'll be an obsessive
co-worker played by Jake Gyllenhaal from
there things seem to spiral out of
control for all characters involved and
let's just say the potential for
post-credit squabbling looms large so
it's best to just steer clear of
coupling up for this cinematic
experience altogether Revolutionary Road
Kate Winslet and Leonardo DiCaprio made
blockbuster magic together in Titanic
and their reunion a decade later for
Revolutionary Road was nothing to shake
a stick at either the two played the
wheelers a couple who shared two kids
and a run-of-the-mill 50s suburbanite
existence but grow increasingly unhappy
with each other and their place in the
world they eventually decide to move to
France where she can be the breadwinner
but when she becomes pregnant with their
third child everything falls apart in a
spectacular series of screen arguments
that showcase the actors gifts for
cutting remarks at the same time the
movie's unblinking look at the demise of
a once perfect couple can easily plant
the seeds of doubt into even the most
promising pair so don't go queuing this
one up on date night away from her Sara
Pauly's adaptation of the Alice Munro
short story the bear came over the
mountain is a masterclass in filmmaking
in many ways but it isn't likely to give
couples a case of Good Vibrations a man
who deeply loves his wife watches as her
Alzheimer's washes away all memory of
the life they shared while she gives her
heart to a fellow patient who suffers
from a similar condition naturally he
tries to break them up by running
interference but he eventually finds
that his wife's broken heart outweighs
his own
needless to say it's heartbreaking and
for any couple hoping they'll grow old
together
this might be a rude wake-up call that
invites all kinds of ethical debates the
gift with the gift joel edgerton proved
his talents extend well beyond a strong
screen presence the accomplished actor
made his writer-director debut with this
eerie mystery thriller and pulled off
one of the most satisfying and
unsettlingly ambiguous endings in the
entire genre as Gordo a man who shares a
mysterious past with Jason Bateman's
character Edgerton lingers at the
margins of everything his old
acquaintance has built for himself a
great job a beautiful wife at home and
even a growing family the title gift can
be seen in several different ways during
the movie but perhaps the movie's most
lasting effect is the gnawing sensation
it leaves you with questions like who
was right are bound to pop up after
letting this mind trip of a movie sink
in so definitely check it out just wait
till your significant other is otherwise
occupied before pressing play thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]